if you've got nothing in the bank right
now zero and you want to buy a house you
want to start making money in the
property market is that possible or is
that a pipe dream well i'm going to be
answering in this video and i'm going to
be explaining
many different strategies that you can
use and you can actually buy houses
right now in the uk using zero money now
you might think it sounds too good to be
true so in this video i'm going to
explain
detailed and give you evidence of how
you can do this so get your notepad get
your pen start taking notes there's four
different ways
the first way is a way called joint
ventures now joint ventures is when you
joint venture with somebody to buy the
house and that person might have money
but might not have knowledge might not
have time might not have skill might not
have experience might not have
inclination but you have got all those
things potentially now
this is such an of anyone that says this
is not possible anyone that says oh no
you need lots of money you need to work
hard and save up i don't underst i'd
love to have them sit next to me and
debate me because it doesn't make any
sense i could name countless people
who have bought properties including
myself this way in fact some people say
samuel leeds sells people dreams on how
they can buy properties without having
any money i don't sell people dreams
people come to me with the dream and the
ambition i write out the checks just go
through my youtube channel um 38
goldsmith lane i believe it was in
birmingham b14 check it out youtube
video i've done it a guy called sacha
saying he bought a house with whose
money my money refurbed the house with
whose money my money did he use any of
his own money no
100 of the development was financed by
my deal he bought the house for 150
grand he refurbished refurbished it
spent 120 000 pounds so in total 270
grand was needed for the deal whose 270
grand was used mine
but it was sachi's deal me and saj
partnered
the property made over 100 000 pounds
profit
what did i do
i just did this wrote the check
i wrote the check sanch did everything
else sags found the deal sad over
oversea saw the builders sad she did
everything it was sach's deal i just
partnered with him and put the money in
so
sach didn't use any of his own money so
he's no money down deal is possible
well yeah
obviously there was some money involved
it was my money but it wasn't his money
um trevor
was a piece of land in lincoln trevor
found a piece of land in lincoln trevor
wanted to buy it trevor didn't have the
money who financed it me how much did it
cost me 330 grand
my cash
with a part in a partnership deal with
trevor
then we bought six houses from scratch
whose money did we use to build six
houses mine
that cost me about half a million and
then we sold off the houses and we split
the profits up how much tr money did
trevor put down of his own money how
much money are you putting into this
deal
nothing nothing zero
what did trevor bring to the table he
found the deal he oversaw the builders
he did everything else you might think
well why would i do that well don't
worry about that for a minute worry
about the fact that can you or can't you
buy properties without using any money
and the answer is yes you can
how much profit are you hoping to make
from this deal within the within the
nine months period i'll make about 180
000 pounds the reason i put the money in
the reason i put the money on so many
deals is because i have only got limited
amount of time in my day i am very busy
sometimes i'd rather put my money into
someone else's deal and let them find
the deal and do everything and and i'll
just take my 50 60 70 whatever it is
percent profit share so joint ventures
i wish someone would argue with me and
that's how i started out when i started
in business when i was like 17 years old
back in like 2008 i didn't have any
money so i had to
bring my competence
bring my confidence my courage my skills
to the table
and let someone else put the money in so
if you're worried because you think i
ain't got any money forget the fact that
you don't have any money find something
else
get skillful get valuable get
knowledgeable and then ask someone to
put the money in
that's what i did and i
asked people to put the money in and
that's how i became a property
millionaire now i put the money in so
that's a very viable white joint
ventures the second way
is
lease option agreements
lease option agreements again i bought
my uh second or third house
using a lease option agreement lease
option agreement is when you buy a house
now and you pay for it later
that's it it's the same as how you buy
sofas and you buy handbags on credit
cards and you buy holidays where you'll
pay buy it down pay for it in a year's
time you can do that with property too
now of course you're gonna need some
money for the legal fees
people get all hung up and
super um you know oh well you can't do
no money because what about the legal
fees it's like come on
come on that's like saying what about
the petrol money to actually get to the
viewing get real when i tell people you
can buy houses and it doesn't matter if
you've not got lots of money i'm talking
about don't worry about saving up a
hundred thousand pound deposit or a
fifty thousand pound deposit to buy the
traditional white i'm not talking about
you know you can live on thin air it
costs money just to live
you know so of course you're gonna need
a little bit of money for maybe for the
legal fees also people get all freaked
out with lease option agreements what
happens if you buy a house and agree to
pay for it later but you can't rent it
out
well that's just the case with any
property investing ever in general ever
suddenly people worry when they're not
putting money in i'm not putting any
money in but what if i don't make any
money
what
what so you want to put no money in and
have a guaranteed
income ironically you kind of do have a
guaranteed income with lease option
agreements because you don't put any
money in okay you have to pay one pound
as an option fee and you have to pay
your legal fees but but you don't put in
a deposit
and then you have the option to buy that
house and you agree with the seller how
long that option lasts in my case on a
property in cleveland road in
blockswitch i agreed with the seller i
would buy it for 81 000 pounds i agreed
that i would buy it anytime within the
next seven years
now i've got seven years to buy that
house for 81 000
if after seven years i don't buy it what
happens i don't have to buy it what
happens is the restriction on the
property lifts and i lose my option
but if i want to buy it the seller has
to sell it to me
so i've got seven years to buy it for 81
000 what do i do
well i put a tenant in there
the tenant starts paying me rent
i saved that rent and then in seven
years use that as the deposit to buy the
house
and seven years later the house had gone
up considerably
it was i had the option to buy it for 81
000 it was worth way over 100 000 when i
came to buy it so after i bought it with
the rent that i saved i was then able to
refinance it and pull out the initial
rent money that i'd put down and get the
rent money back
too good to be true i know
it is ridiculous what you can do in
business and in property when you
actually know
what you're doing lease option
agreements is something that's done all
ian um paterson
one of my first students in 2016 2017 he
built up a multi-million pound property
portfolio using lease option agreements
he was all over the newspapers
and um many other people my most recent
guy uh pete i think his name is pete
turner i did a youtube interview with
him a few weeks ago pete found a
property a 26 apartment block building
in sunderland and agreed to buy it with
agreed to buy it for 600 i think it was
600 grand but then said to the seller
can i buy it in seven years time
the seller said as long as you rent it
from me in the meantime so he's now
paying the seller a monthly rent
but he's making a huge profit from it
every month because he's renting it out
like a rent-a-ramp
he's got the option to buy it in seven
years for 600 it just got valued last
month at 800 grand
so in the last few months since he got
the deal he's pushed the value up
because now it's fully rented out he's
got a commercial valuation on it he's
already made a couple hundred thousand
pounds pete had
nothing
pete didn't even have the money to pay
for the legal fees then the small little
reefer that was needed there was to be
fair because it was a big building there
was about 20 grand that pete needed and
i was saying to pete pizza my student i
was saying p
just find the 20 grand just do it and
people say i got 20 grand i was like
pete this is gonna make you thousands
and thousands of pounds every month from
the rent
and you're gonna have the option to buy
it in seven years it's going to go
massively up in value if you can't find
the 20 grand you need shooting in the
face just get the 20 grand
and pete comes from a um you know from a
foster care home background and he was
in a rough place and he just didn't have
any money and i'm a little slight where
he has to get the money he could get a
loan you get a credit card because i'm
not talking about getting debt for bad
debt reasons getting debt where the
debt's going to eat you up i'm talking
about getting debt
where the debt is going to actually
serve you and make you loads of money
that's what we call good debt all
businesses have good debt
people i can't get any debt i can't so
in the end one of my mentors within the
academy said to pete how about this peak
i'll put the 20 grand in
so it makes what does that mean for pete
that means that it's a no money down
deal no zero none
pete paid nothing
but tony my mentor said to pete but i
want 50 of the profits
now pete's thinking well 50 of the
profits is better than 100 of nothing
i'd rather have 50 of something than 100
of nothing and i can't get the deal
unless i use tony's money so pete said
yes
so pete and tony formed this joint
venture partnership tony mentors him
through it now they have this 26
apartment block building making the most
fortune pete's financially free people
how much in nothing that's lease option
agreement i wish i could sit with
someone and argue with them about lease
option agreements anyone that says it's
not possible oh because of the mortgage
payments or the insurances they'll come
up try and make themselves look
intelligent as to what oh it's not
possible because of this come and talk
to me then it's completely possible
ridiculous third way
packaging and selling deals
i had true story
a few months ago
i was running a crash course one pound
event there was two kids i say kids
because they weren't adults kids
teenagers i think one of them was 16
kids
and they're blind
with sticks two blind kids at my crash
course
i'm selling
i'm at my crash course i'm making a sale
at the end of the day i'm saying hey
i've got some advanced training this is
what it is it's 2 000 pounds i'm selling
some people get upset with me because i
sell and they say oh samuel sells
expensive courses i don't care on this
occasion i cared because i'm thinking
there's two kids
they're blind
i'm feeling a little bit
um i don't want these kids to sign up
and then and then what then they fail
and then they say samuel leads maybe
going to debt to go on one of his
courses damn
so i'm selling and these kids get up
and they start with their sticks going
to the back of the room to sign up i'm
like damn i stopped selling
i'll go to the back of the room
i'm like you guys okay what's going on
yeah man we just want to sign up
i'm like damn
i don't know if we can do this because
you're not you're underage i don't know
if it's legal i'm also thinking
obviously they've got disability
they push
and they manage to get themselves on the
program and i'm thinking damn this is
worrying
they come on the program on the deal
selling masterclass it's a 2 000 program
on the program not afterwards not next
week or the month after
on the program
they sold a deal i made 3 000 pounds so
if you're willing to have the deal i'm
willing to sell it to you not the
finder's fee is what do you want to do
what were the names abdul and shang this
by the way made the newspapers this was
in i think it was i can't remember the
name of the newspaper but i'll flash it
up this made the newspapers it's like
if they hadn't have been successful it
would have probably made the newspapers
for another reason
but it's like what did they actually do
i tell you what they did they followed
my exact training
what did they do they rang agents
they said what have you got for me
i'm looking to buy something quick cash
below market value what you got well i
got this for 200 grand i've got this for
150 that one for 200 grams if i buy it
now with the tape 170.
oh wow i get if you move really quickly
they are motivated to sell i think they
might take 170. okay cool hold that for
me
phone an investor and on the part of the
program is i'll give them access to my
investors
stop further investors hey
i need you to sign a non-disclosure
agreement i've got a deal the investor
signs and non-disclosure agreements is
what you got for me i just spoke to
sandra the estate agent it's on the
market for 200. i think i can get it
wrapped up for 170.
here's the address here's the details
i'll negotiate on your behalf you can't
cut me out because you've signed the
non-disclosure agreement if i'm getting
this wrapped up today will you pay me 3
000 perhaps
yes i will i'm looking for a deal that
looks like a good deal great let me get
back on the phone like
put a few calls
a bit of crunching obviously look deal
selling is something that's not to be
taken lightly it's a proper business
i'm not suggesting you go out there
tomorrow and start selling loads of
deals when you don't know what you're
doing needs knowledge but does it need
money
no
zero
knowledge not money deal or selling
rent to rent
control i had a couple teenagers again
most of my by the way do you know that
only two percent of my audience that
watch me on youtube are teenagers
the vast majority are above 25 years old
but i'm talking about teenagers because
if you're a 26 year old punk watching
this right now thinking i've only got
five grand
i've got teenagers that have had nothing
that have been successful dan
and joe
teenagers came on some training learned
about rent to rent didn't have enough
didn't have any money didn't have enough
money to stop buying houses so what they
did is they rented a property in
sheffield they rented it for 800 pounds
and then they rented it out on a room by
room basis for 1600 pounds they doubled
the rent overnight
now of course they've got expenses and
running costs
but they're still left with a clean
profit of 400 to 500 pounds per month
clean profit that that didn't take them
any money they didn't have to buy the
house they just rented it and then put
tenants in and they they structured it
very well with my support
that property now they were teenagers
they're not teenagers anymore now dan
and joe are in their 20s
now dan and joe are like 20 22.
they got that deal years ago they've
still got it today it's still bringing
in 500 pounds a month in sheffield they
went and got a bunch more rent to rents
they're now completely financially free
dan just graduated from university and
he doesn't need a job
how crazy is that imagine going to uni
and the whole purpose of uni is to help
you get a degree that's going to help
you get a job and you get a degree and
you go
i don't actually need a job
so that is just some ways joint ventures
lease option agreements packaging deals
rent to rent controlling properties how
you can make significant sums of money
in property starting with sarah all you
need knowledge
courage
a bit of time prepared to roll your
sleeves up
no excuses
so if you know somebody a journalist or
someone that runs their mouth online
that says it's not possible samuel leads
oh he's full of [ __ ]
let's talk man let's meet and have a
debate because not only have i done
thousands and thousands had thousand
thousand students i've also done
hundreds and hundreds of deals myself
i've seen this i see this on the daily
basis
so
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you